Batman in this movie is self-centered
he's cocky he loves to be loved did you
find inspiration for this character from
anywhere in particular what are you
suggesting Diane I'm suggesting that I
saw some similarities towards certain
people who've been in the public eye of
of late you know it to suggest that
Batman is anything like anybody who's in
the news you are suggesting a level of
carnage you got it so terrible about is
that that's so bad well what was the
most fun part of playing is character
what's one is is that we all know Batman
he's iconic characters been around
forever
and to kind of go in and change some of
the things that we know about him like
just kind of alter the rules a little
bit just a couple of quick questions are
you a builder or a Smasher when it comes
to Legos builder if there was one piece
of wardrobe you can steal from Batman's
closet what would it be the boots are
you a Lego builder or a Smasher what's
the Lego smash where someone breaks up
someone's achievement when they they
worked hard on you someone comes through
and says no yeah sure I'll do that okay
you know there is something in men and
young boys in testosterone that likes to
destroy things and you've seen things we
would not understand yeah I I've seen
things that you wouldn't understand and
destroying is fun but I'm a builder I'm
a bridge builder if there was one piece
of wardrobe you could steal from your
character what would it be
yeah let's take a look take a cape I
like the sea hands the sea hands yeah
it's great you're doing a good job
how does Robin feel about you Batman
dick here looks up to me in every way
well of course I do
we are the best team ever he idolizes me
to no end I want to be just like you
when I grow up Padre little guy wants to
grow up to be a crime-fighting vigilante
superhero just like me no matter how
dangerous and illegal it is look dad
don't call me Dad just go to your room
okay
oh I've been parented
but answer just a little tighter I can
only look you in the eyes right now
[Music]
you